that's how about your recent documentary
it's about the Internet yes and you did
this document on the Internet is
fascinating you yourself are not on
social media now I'm I'm not on Facebook
or Twitter however on the internet you
find me
Facebook Twitter but it's all imposed us
I do have a lot of doppelgangers out
there and it's fine fine for me if
they're my unpaid bodyguards their
unpaid Stooges somehow who somehow give
me a fence of defense of some somehow
let them to battle out there so there
you have your ok with people
impersonating you on the internet
because they feel like it creates a wall
between that madness and you in a way
I'm clinically sane so to speak yeah
there's no madness here you encode will
see you know you propose that the
internet someday could become self-aware
do you think that could really be true I
mean if we look further into the future
and in people much more competent than
me start to think about it and I'm
asking a question which comes a couple
of times during the film I'm asking does
the internet dream of itself and it's
nobody of course has an answer but it's
a very deep question and sometimes it is
better to pose a question that may not
get an answer and it's it's very
fascinating what is possible on the
Internet you can for example through
MRIs you can read thoughts you can read
for example if I read a text to you in
English and then I read the same text in
Spanish the MRI has a different pattern
because Spanish and English grammar have
different patterns and it is
recognizable ultimately they think and
it will not be very far away you can
tweet thoughts right there won't be any
I didn't take no tweeting no typing you
have a thought and you can tweet it to
your community
I god forbid a time Leonard my thoughts
are just out there we have a clip the
glorious times of the future yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh sure yeah I'll be
arrested very quickly let's take a clip
look at this clip from lo and behold
this particular machine is so ugly on
the inside it is beautiful it has unique
odor a delicious old odor from all the
old part it consists of modems CPU logic
units memory power supply all the things
you need to make an efficient computer
world
this machine served as the first node of
the internet for decades
and it was from here that the first
message was sent that's amazing to see
the real night 1969 I think yes
1969 lo and behold reveries of the
connected world is now in theaters and
available on-demand Amazon video and
iTunes and it's fascinating because it's
so much a part of our world now and
we're not even thinking about it and you
take us from the start which is really
fantastic
Vernor Hertzog please come back I just
love how ya
[Applause]
you